[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce contrôle de vol confirmant que nous
avons des evrs d'ingénieurs
ingénieux rapportant avoir effectué
une
montée en rotation au décollage une
descente en vol stationnaire un
atterrissage et une rotation vers le bas
et nos données altimétriques ont
confirmé que l'ingéniosité a effectué
son premier vol
le premier vol d'un avion motorisé
sur une autre planète
[Applaudissements]
et l'ingéniosité est inférieure à 1,8 kilogrammes
juste quatre livres
et dans cette ingéniosité de quatre livres doit
être capable de voler
dans cette atmosphère très mince et être capable
de survivre et d'
opérer de manière autonome sur Mars, nous avons
trois objectifs qui sont en  conformément aux
objectifs au niveau de l'agence de la nasa,
le premier est de démontrer ici sur
terre qu'il est
possible d'effectuer un vol motorisé contrôlé
dans la fine atmosphère de mars
nous avons fait que le deuxième objectif est
d'effectuer ce vol réel sur mars
bien nous sommes  sur le point de récupérer des données très
bientôt ici sur ce premier vol
et le troisième est de renvoyer des données pour
informer les ingénieurs
euh travaillant sur la conception du futur
générations d'hélicoptères mars